manchmal ist es wirklich ein wenig
erschreckend auf welche ideen
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
kommen dieses mal lässt doktor
frankenstein größen eine
forschungsgruppe hat mäusen menschliche
nervenzellen also den zellen eingebaut
und mal geguckt was so passiert und das
im wahrsten sinne des wortes sie haben
nämlich ein sichtfenster in den schädel
gebaut um das wachstum zu beobachten und
was sie dabei sehen konnten finde ich
beunruhigend jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
die hirnforschung macht immer größere
fortschritte
aber manchmal denke ich um welchen preis
ein forschungsteam des soc institute for
biological studies im kalifornischen la
jolla in den usa hat jetzt mäusen hirn
organe eingepflanzt und dann durch ein
loch im schädel mit einem sichtfenster
beobachtet was mit den fällen geschieht
die forschungsfrage war können solche
zellen auch außerhalb der petrischale
wachsen und was machen sie dann sofort
ließen sie die zellkulturen im labor 50
tage lang wachsen und setzen sie dann
den mäusen ein damit sie die zellen dann
im mäuse gehirn beobachten konnten
manipulierten sie die gene der zellen so
dass sie grün leuchteten und das
verblüffende die zellen wuchsen und
nicht nur das nach nur zwei wochen
hatten sich die zellen mit dem
blutkreislauf der wirtstiere verbunden
und wurden dadurch mit sauerstoff und
nährstoffen versorgt und innerhalb von
drei monaten wuchsen die zellen dann
weiter und verbreiteten sich im mäuse
hören sie wuchsen tief ins gehirn hinein
und jetzt wird es ein bisschen spooky
die beiden strukturen verbanden sich die
menschlichen und tierischen hirnzellen
takten sich aufeinander ein und bildeten
laut der forschungsgruppe ein
gemeinsames neuronales netzwerk hatten
die forscherinnen und forscher jetzt
super intelligente mäuse geschaffen
eine wirklich erschreckende vorstellung
ein schreckensszenario super mäuse
brechen aus dem labor aus und übernehmen
die weltherrschaft naja das
forschungsteam untersuchte die lösung
kam zu einem eher beruhigenden ergebnis
keine veränderung
weder das verhalten der mäuse noch ihr
lernvermögen ließen auf eine gesteigerte
intelligenz schließen allerdings schloss
der forschungsleiter nicht aus dass es
veränderungen gegeben haben könnte die
sie aber noch nicht festgestellt hätten
allerdings nehmen sie diese ergebnisse
jetzt zum anlass mit ihren forschungen
fortzufahren
mit diesem versuchsaufbau also
menschlichen nervenzellen im tierkörper
wollen sie in zukunft schizophrenie
alzheimer autismus parkinson und
weiteren krankheiten erforschen sie
schließen aufgrund ihrer annahmen und
der ergebnisse dieser forschungsarbeiten
aus dass menschliche fähigkeiten auf die
tiere übergehen können wenn er als
erstes neues zum thema medizinische
experimente aller frankenstein und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir
täglich vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
über mich in der redaktion vom krieg so
mitmachen mit themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen
was hier bei pixum passiert und so
begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines
goodie einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken unvorstellbar kopf soll auf
9 körper transplantiert werden
das ist auch aller doktor frankenstein
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran